if you want to
Elevate yourself and be more successful
you must get over the pride of learning
because the of knowing because this
pride in knowing I see this happen all
the time people feel embarrassed if they
don't know
or they feel so attached to having the
right answer that they feel
uncomfortable if they're in a discussion
and somebody says something different
and they learn I mean it's a barrier and
those who give it up then have they go
radically to higher levels because it
gives them the capacity to take in or
the capacity to change their mind is it
a problem if you change your mind
you learn you change your mind that's
called growing but there's kind of an
ego attachment to it oh you were wrong
oh you change your mind I mean okay so
that whole thing's connected it's
attached to knowing and and you know and
and thinking that's a big deal or
something rather than the humility that
you're referring to I mean it's not
false humility it's just actually
recognizing what one doesn't know